Bill Maher hitting the woke left with
another dose of reality the liberal
comedian pointing out this hard truth
about today's Democrat Party and who
gets canceled
nobody ever gets canceled for being too
woke so you can say the craziest thing
like men can have babies
and then nobody even though people are
thinking well that's kind of nuts nobody
will say it they'll just fall in line uh
yeah yeah exactly that's what I've
always thought mental babies sure I saw
a dude who was glowing yesterday you
know I mean it's and that's the problem
and it's totally insane cowardice
and speaking of being too woke Joe
Biden's education secretary refusing to
Define what a woman is
can you please define for me what is a
woman our focus at the department is to
provide equal access to students what
does HHS say the definition of a woman
is I lead the Department of Education
and my job is to make sure that all
students have access to public education
which includes co-curricular activities
all right so there you have it we had a
Supreme Court Justice who couldn't
Define what a woman was and now Cardona
who's the head of the Department of
Education uh Geraldo what are they
hiding
well they're hiding the fact that this
should be a biological question not a
political question
biology says that the vast majority of
men have penises the vast majority of
women have reproductive organs not all
and they should be exceptions for the
one percent of whatever it is uh and uh
or uh
accommodations
but I I think that's going well
I don't need to say anything yeah yeah
but I I think that we have to get over
the the abject Terror that that question
raises the fact that the education
secretary could not even as haltingly as
I am now describing uh the distinction
between men and women he should have
been able to make an attempt rather than
say I don't know uh I only am in charge
of the ABCs okay all right Brian is more
right I mean can the left basically get
away with anything and while the people
uh on the uh on the right
I think there's a huge Lane for
Democrats like feel more I think it's
opening up Andrew Cuomo's doing it on
the radio and he sees it he's pointing
out the lunacy in these positions they
can't be backed by fact or logic and I
think if Democrats are smart they will
start picking out that lane no one's
ever going to say Bill Maher is a
conservative but they can say he's
logical and he's showing logic and I
heard Andrew come the other night on the
radio I'm like he's he whether he
believes it or not he's showing logic
when it comes to crime and what have you
so I think that lane is opening up which
would be better for the country just a
logical debate instead of I have no
problem having a UFC fighter who's uh
pretending to be a woman fight a man and
get and split open their skull and
what's happening in sports destroying uh
what's going on with swimming and
everything else I just think there's a
logical element to it and Bill Moore is
aggravating all Democrats by saying
things like this and he's widening up
his audience as is Pierce Morgan Dana
how long do you think it will take if if
there is an ultimate separation for
example of women's sports and a separate
Lane for trans women sports how long do
you think it'll take before the left
calls this segregation
well I think that they're refusing to
even just by refusing to answer the
question they know the answer they
refuse to answer it because again let's
go back it's not just he's the
Department of Education Secretary
he works for Joe Biden yeah this is a
policy preference for from the president
of the United States he doesn't want the
question answered they're the ones who
put out the guidance the other day that
they want to change basically on girl
Sports and say well they left a little
wishy-washy so that you individual
schools can figure it out that is not
leadership that is not a compromise it
is a total cop-out the other thing I'd
point out is JK Rowling she's been a
stalwart supporter of women so HBO is
about to roll out this new Harry Potter
series and they're getting flooded with
all of these comments like is she going
to be involved well into HBO's credit
they're sticking by her good and saying
she wrote the books like we've been in
business with her for 20 years yes she's
going to be involved if companies yes
right if you stand up to it maybe it
will end um and in cat's book I know
you're going to talk about maybe your
book but you talk a little bit about
this about being able to say what is
just the truth without worrying about
being worried about getting canceled
yeah I do and I talk about how this
current status of things is not good for
anyone if your most important issue
let's say that you're like a trans
rights activist you shouldn't like this
either because as we saw with Geraldo
and with Meats at times with people in
government when you bring this up people
are like oh I don't say something wrong
and that is not how people learn to
understand each other and have real
conversations because just because you
feel like oh you can't say that people
are still going to think it you can't
legislate that used to be race we used
to wonder black and white now we're
talking about gender it's too sensitive
to talk about gender now it's crazy I
feel it well-intentioned conversation
should be allowed as long as the
intentions are good let's talk to each
other let's get to know each other and
then we can all get along that were the
rule I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now